كحلي
ازرق
احمر
اخضر
[موسيقى]
انا حمد محمد المطالعه فنان تشكيلي قطري
عندي عمل الوان يعني اشوف الالوان بصوره
اغاني على اليوتيوب
لاني حتى الاختبار مرتين ما ما صدقت
الدكتور يوم قال لنا فيك مثلا
مرحله الدراسه المواضيع جدا كانت بسيطه
رحله الى شاطئ البحر فكنت انا الون غير عن
الباقي مثل ما يقولون ربعي فكانت عندنا
مدرسه هي الوحيده اللي تقدر ان انا فيني
اعمل واحد مع ذلك ما كانت تكسر مجادير في
بالعكس كانت تشجعني شكرا ابله فاتن
الهدف اني اخلي الناس تجرب تجربه ما قد
مرت فيها انه يشوفون الالوان بالطريقه
اللي انا اشوفها بعمل الوان فهي تجربه جدا
ممتعه وغير عن المعلومات حتى لو عندي فرصه
ان انا اشوف الالوان بعيون العالم انا
ماضي لان انا ما اشوف الالوان بعيوني انا
احلى